hey what is up guys mkbhd here and in a
world with 1080p smartphones now
becoming more and more popular with the
droid dna and the oppo find 5 and the
zte grand s and the lg optimus g pro and
the huawei ascend mate and many others
two have set themselves pretty clearly
as
the kings of the 1080p smartphones and
they're pretty much guaranteed to be
competing with each other side by side
in stores around the country nationwide
you guys already know it's the htc one
versus the samsung galaxy s4 two
flagships we're going to be seeing a lot
of this year so without any further ado
let's compare them and see which one
ends up being the better choice for you
so we'll start with the obvious and
that's build quality and the htc one is
arguably the best built phone that's
ever been made and it's definitely the
best built phone that htc has ever made
and it's built so well that it brings
into question the build quality of other
smartphones like the galaxy s4 because
that's actually at this point now the
physically biggest difference between
these two phones is the material and the
construction that put them together
and that's the funny thing because the
first impression that people get of the
smartphone is just holding it in the
hand so if i gave one of these and one
of these to the same person they would
probably immediately give you an answer
about which one they like more which one
feels better in the hand which one they
think they would rather buy
and then you turn the phones on and you
get a whole different experience but the
immediate first impression you get about
the phone is how it feels now i want you
guys to hear this i want you guys to
hear this because this is probably the
scariest part of the difference between
the way these are built this is the htc
one i'm going to go ahead and flex it at
the strongest that i would ever flex a
phone this is going to be full strength
flex and just listen
and the phone barely budges it's not
going to bend all that much and i'm
probably going to damage it if i do any
more stress to it but that's a whole lot
of pressure to put a phone under this is
the galaxy s4 and have a listen to this
i'm going to flex it at about 20 percent
and you can see it's flexing when i do
that and there's a whole lot of
different weird noises and popping and
creaking going on because the back is
removable and that's probably a little
bit of it but just
i feel like i'm going to break the phone
if i do that anymore that's about 50 i'm
not going to put any more stress on it
that's concerning to me that there's
such a big disparity in the build
quality between these phones now samsung
has said and i've interviewed people on
the samsung team uh that they have their
own reasons for using plastic and
they're perfectly valid reasons and
there are pros and cons to using plastic
and there are pros and cons to using
metal like we already know the pros to a
metal built phone are build quality
durability and feel in the hand and like
i said with the htc one it's a phone
that i just kind of want to pick up and
mess around with it's got the best feel
in the hand of any phone i've ever used
but the cons of metal are number one
chipping it tends to get chipped more
easily it's not as easily to easily
broken like the galaxy s4 is plastic but
it's a lot easier to chip if you drop it
and number two temperature sensitivity
when the htc one gets cold it gets
really cold and when the htc one gets
hot it gets really hot because metal is
naturally more conductive than plastic
there's also another minor contour metal
where there's not as great a radio
sensitivity so the radios kind of have
to have their own place to go through
the bands of the phone the bluetooth and
wi-fi and 3g and 4g reception might not
be as good if the phone is all metal but
luckily the htc one takes care of that
with a few bands of plastic around the
phone and then if we look at the pros
and cons of plastic they are the exact
opposite switched around upside down so
the cons of plastic are build quality
fuel in the hand durability and the pros
of plastic are radio strength and all
the same cons that we had with metal
overall though if i had to pick a winner
for build quality and sort of structure
in the way it feels i think nine out of
ten people would agree that the htc one
takes that uh it's probably the best
built phone out there and if you hand
both phones to someone on the street and
say here which one do you think costs
more they'll probably have a pretty
quick answer for you now besides the
actual material that these phones are
made of there are also some physical
differences between the phones that
potential buyers will notice so when you
hold them side by side you'll notice the
shape of the phones with the galaxy s4
being much more square and the one being
more taper along the back and there's
also the weight naturally the metal htc
one will feel significantly heavier in
the hand and in fact it's actually been
said that the galaxy s4 feels really
light it feels lighter than it looks so
there's a pretty big weight difference
here there's also the difference in the
button layouts so around the outside i
mentioned in the htc one review which
will be linked below that like button
the top power button takes some getting
used to it's on the top instead of the
side like other devices and i stand by
that it's still a little bit quirky at
first and the volume rockers are on the
opposite sides on these phones so again
a minor difference but they're like a
mirror image of each other it's
something you'll have to take a few days
to get used to when switching and also
on the front you also have a major
button difference so the galaxy s4 has a
physical home button in the middle plus
a capacitive menu button on the left and
a capacitive back button on the right
that works for the most part and on the
htc one you have the logo in the center
which does nothing when you press it and
you also have a capacitive home button
on the right and back button on the left
so again mirror images of each other no
menu button which means that certain
apps will get their own gigantic
dedicated menu button taking up precious
screen real estate but again that's a
minor difference not something that
you'll never get used to another
gargantuan difference though is these
speakers the galaxy s4 has a single
rear-facing speaker on the back of the
phone that can actually be completely
covered and muffled with a badly placed
single finger by accident the htc one on
the other hand has two massive
front-facing stereo speaker drivers that
absolutely blow every other device off
the water i've done tests with these
it's in the htc one review if you want
to watch it but they produce insanely
great crisp loud and clear audio that
still impresses me today and i've been
using the phone for weeks so it's really
great speakers now onto the performance
side of things if you've seen my review
of each of these phones which like i
said are below you'll notice that
they're both spec'd very very well both
of them are endowed with that new
qualcomm snapdragon 600 processor
similar clock speeds not identical but
like i said pretty much everything is
very well specced here and they also
also get similar benchmark scores so
they're very very close in terms of the
performance department but i did notice
a bit of stuttering on some places in
the galaxy s4 particularly in the
gallery and sometimes in the
notification shade that i absolutely did
not notice in the htc one now i
mentioned that the htc one in the review
was a very quick phone and it's very
responsive phone throughout that video
and i stand by that and i would actually
give a slight performance advantage at
least in consistency to the htc one it's
just overall a really really
blisteringly fast phone even though
again they come out with about the same
battery life and you really probably
won't notice a performance difference if
you don't use them both but i would give
just that slight edge to the one now
another thing is about the operating
systems the galaxy s4 is actually
running a newer version of android
underneath android 4.2 instead of the
htc ones 4.1 so you will get some of
those new android 4.2 feature editions
on the galaxy s4 like lock screen
widgets and quick settings in the
notification panel that you won't see on
the htc one at least right now i say
that because htc has so much writing on
this phone that i wouldn't be surprised
to see an update right around the corner
for this guy very soon now that being
said there's another hotly debated area
when comparing these two flagships and
that is their cameras so on the outside
the htc one has a pretty flat element as
you can see while the galaxy s4 is
protrudes little but the htc one has a
four ultra pixel camera while the galaxy
s4 has a more traditional 13 megapixel
sensor inside and it's tough because
usually smartphone cameras no matter
what are pretty similar and both take
such similar great pictures that it's
not really worth comparing the two but
with this htc one it's pretty obvious
that with only four megapixels they're
taking a completely different approach
the camera optics very risky but to sum
it all up the galaxy s4 takes better
more accurate more detailed pictures in
regular light while the htc one takes
better more accurate more detailed
pictures in low light the s4 in low
light is it's alright and the htc one in
regular light is it's all right i mean
there are obviously way more software
features with the galaxy s4 and a sweet
camera interface taken from the galaxy
camera to back it all up so they're
making it look very pretty but these
comparisons really do most of the
talking so you can see that in low light
the galaxy s4 does a decent job but the
htc one does a better job again in low
light the galaxy s4 does a decent job
but the one does a better job in regular
light though which i don't know about
you but that's where i take most of my
pictures
you can see that the htc ones four
megapixel shot kind of falls apart when
you try to zoom in or look at any detail
but the galaxy s4 is 13 megapixel shot
is just crispy and crunchy all the way
through thanks to that improved sensor
from the galaxy s3 honestly if i was a
huge picture taking person with my phone
my pick would be the galaxy s4 every
single time and i know that a lot of you
guys are suckers for pixels just like i
am and uh the more flexibility i have
with zooming in and cropping my pictures
with 13 megapixels the better another
slide difference though that nobody ever
seems to talk about between these
cameras is the wider angle lens on the
htc ones front and back facing cameras
so the front-facing camera is a wider
angle to allow more people into the shot
so if you need selfies with your friends
you can fit more friends and even the
back facing camera is also a slightly
wider angle so the htc one check out how
many robots are in the frame with the
ones camera versus the s4s pretty neat
stuff if you ask me a lot of people
won't notice that because if you only
use one of the phones and not the other
you'll never know but there is
definitely a noticeable difference in
crop between the two we were speaking
about pixels so i'll just go ahead and
say that these are both awesome 1080p
smartphone displays the galaxy s4
happens to be an amoled display coming
in at 5 inches so you'll get deep blacks
and very contrasty images and of course
a very high pixel density and the htc
one is an lcd panel at 4.7 inches so an
even slightly higher pixel density and
you'll get much brighter and more
readable looks outdoors on the htc one
and you also get more accurate colors
with that lcd panel so both of these i
like a lot you're going to get crazy
crazy sharp images and video when you're
looking at any content on either of
these phones and then of course there is
htc sense versus touchwiz
and
this one's your call they're both
android so you can make it whatever you
want it to be no matter what it looks
like out the box so at the end of the
day no matter how you look at it these
are
both great phones and whatever you
happen to go for if you go for the one
or if you go for the s4 your money will
probably be very well spent and i
wouldn't have any problem recommending
either one
and i doubt you'll be disappointed if
you do pull the trigger so you really
can't go wrong with either one
so put your money where your heart is so
there you go that is pretty much every
argument for and against each of these
two super phones the htc one and the
galaxy s4 what is your pick what would
you rather have what have you already
bought over the other which one would
you say is the better smartphone
personally for my personal pick for
those of you wondering uh i would i
would give the nod to the htc one as my
potential
most used phone now uh that being said
if i'm just going to go leave somewhere
and pick one of these phones to take
with me eight times out of ten i'll take
the htc one but if i'm going somewhere
where i need uh to take a lot of
pictures for example i'm probably going
to give the nod to the galaxy s4 just
because the camera is better it's just a
better camera uh that being said htc one
i really really hope it comes to verizon
in some shape or form some variant maybe
a black or red and black version on lte
bands that would really make this the
ultimate daily driver for me throw some
stock android on it and it's a keeper uh
but yeah go ahead and leave your
comments down below what you think is
the better device or which one you would
pick and a thumbs up is definitely
always appreciated but either way thank
you for watching this video and i'll
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
you